in a nutshell Constantine give us your
program if we vote constantinian to be
supreme leader how do we how do we must
kill the Jews
[Laughter]
it's okay how do we how do we push back
over there sorry was that too much for
clothes cringing over there
the jokes guys that you remember them do
you have it back you have a class what
what do we do uh well I don't have a
plan uh what I think we do is we build
alternative ecosystems uh in every way
um I think we build alternative media I
think we build alternative education I
think we build alternative everything
and then let the market decide do you
want your kids to be educated in a
welcome address or not and I don't think
most people do uh do you want to watch
media that is complete or do
you not I don't think most people do I
think it's really as simple as that and
those of us who understand what's going
on have a responsibility to step up
um that's all it is and you know Andy
Shaw is somewhere in the room they
created comedy Unleashed they're doing
this in comedy you're doing it with
media we're doing with media I think
there's scope for bigger things and
eventually what will happen is there
will be the not woke or anti-work
corporations that just come along and go
look I don't care about this I just
want to sell condoms or wherever it is
right and I think that's really the
future the future it for me Isn't work
or anti-work the Futures post work we've
got to move Beyond this craziness and I
think those of us who've been trying to
push back against it we've got some good
results uh we're actually winning people
over uh and maybe actually it's not
asked it's them they're winning people
over for our side by going crazy and
crazy and crazier
um and eventually I just look I I said
this to you earlier and I've said this a
number of times I don't think the
British public want to turn on the TV
screen to watch the England game to see
3X England football players talking
about racism I also by the way don't
think they want to see someone talking
about how BLM is a neo-marquist
organization I have this deeply seated
feeling that they just want to watch the
football
right and so I think it's just weird
isn't it they're mental so I think once
that is available that is what they will
go for but it has to be available and
someone has to build that so here's the
bit that worries me a little bit because
we had Dave Rubin on our show who is a
YouTube host
and he was part of this thing called the
intellectual dark web it was this group
of people who were self-professed
liberals and their idea was they weren't
of the left or the right they were just
you know truth Seekers and they were
going to find out some new common ground
and one by one a lot of those characters
have basically picked a tribe and after
a year or two years or three years in
the furnace of argument
they give up on this liberal notion that
there is Common Ground they give up on
the idea that compromise is possible and
I guess if you're just into building
alternative institutions that's what I
worry about are we are we now going to
pick for all of our kids we're going to
choose a right-wing School the left
wings of what I just said right I didn't
say we need a football channel that
talks about how blm's and neo-marxist
organization I just said we need a
football channel to broadcast football
with none of this political crap right
and it's the same with education it
doesn't have to be an anti-work
education where you sit you know
breaking down critical three theory for
five-year-olds I just I we just teach
kids what they need to know to live life
the social justice kind of warrior
believes in that binary they have that
in their head that if you are not woke
you are anti-work that's what how do you
get over that how do you survive that
kind of binary I have no desire to speak
to uh these woke extremists I think
there are a lot of people who fall into
wokeness because they know they've never
been exposed to different ideas but
those people that you're talking about
you're not going to win them over there
they're the Taliban of this ideology
right but there are lots of moderate
Muslims that can be easily persuaded
that this way of doing his isn't great
uh I I don't think you win them over and
look this you look at history I mean
this this is kind of how it always goes
the small minority of people argue about
what the mass of people should do and
let's see who wins but so do you give up
on the existing mainstream institutions
that's really my question like can can
the BBC be rescued can be existing and
the universities be rescued you know or
are we are some people in America have
gone down the path it's time to create a
new universe it's quite time to create
new institutions where do you stand on
that can can what used to be these
binding shared institutions be saved I
wish they were able to be saved I don't
know the answer to that question
um I I don't certainly my experiences
within the BBC and it's quite useful
again coming back to your point about
immigrant privilege being me because I
have dark skinned foreign name blah blah
blah so when I used to go in there I
didn't have any profile they'd assume
I'm one of them
and they talk openly about what their
agenda is and believe you me they have
an agenda and I'm not talking about the
executives at the top level I'm talking
about people at the lowest rungs of the
BBC they know what they're doing and
they say it in terms we have the
cultural reins of power in our hands and
it's time to you know diverse the equity
all this other work stuff so you know
are you going to change that I after
you've employed a bunch of University
graduates who all believe this I don't
know are you
um so uh the only thing I know is that
isn't my fight right I can't do that I
can't change the BBC I can't change the
universities I can do my bit which is
a small percentage of the media
ecosystem I can change that and I am
increasingly moving away from being
anti-woke because some of the excesses
of that side of things are starting to
do my head in as well such as
I mean you know that Meme online of I
support the current thing we've now got
to a point where quite a lot of people
that I used to respect are in the
position of I oppose the current thing
and to them it's enough that the
guardian or the the whatever is pro
Ukraine for them to lose their over
it completely and and start
regurgitating crap about our country
they couldn't find on a map
um which most of them could because
we're going to get to you good I I have
some things to say to you about that
um
and so to me seeing this teenage
oppositional Defiance disorder from
adults it does my head in I'm
sorry for swearing but it does my head